يستعد المقاتلون للمعركة النهائية
ضد ما تبقى من ما يسمى
بالدولة الإسلامية
المتحصنة الآن في زاوية صغيرة من الأرض في
شرق سوريا
بدعم جوي من التحالف ، وقد طردت
القوات الديمقراطية السورية المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية
من الجميع باستثناء جزء صغير
منها.  المنطقة الواقعة على طول نهر الفرات
، من السهل رؤية الكثير من الحركة
داخل الجيب المحاصر على بعد نصف
ميل فقط
حيث يتردد أصداء إطلاق النار عبر المنطقة
الحرام ، حيث توقف القتال النشط منذ فترة ،
ويقول هؤلاء الجنود
حسنًا ،
لذا أخبرنا الجنود هنا أن الوضع
هادئ.  آخر أسبوع على الأقل
أو نحو ذلك ،
ولكن في اللحظة
التي أخبرني فيها الجندي أن
هناك هبوطًا دائريًا قادمًا هناك ،
وأعتقد في هذه الحالة أن مصطلحًا
نسبيًا
هو قيادة القوات المناهضة لداعش
في الجبهة
و  يحذر من افتراض أن الحرب قد
انتهت تقريبًا من
الشعارات المفضلة ، حيث كانت الدولة الإسلامية
باقية وتتوسع والتي تبدو الآن
وكأنها منذ زمن بعيد مع انهيار الدولة الإسلامية.
إنهم يتركون
ورائهم فائض من النقود ، إذا جاز التعبير ، فهذه عملة من فئة الخمس درهم
لا تساوي الآن أي شيء
لا قيمة له مثل حطام
وهمهم الفاضل بن ويتمان سي إن إن شرق سوريا